[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara hallweg guten Abend und
willkommen alles Wichtige zur Champions
League hat nachher Norbert lemann einen
schönen guten Abend auch von mir und das
sind die Nachrichtenthemen von
heute krisendiplomatie in Brüssel die EU
Staats und Regierungschefs suchen nach
einer gemeinsamen Position zum
Nahostkrieg Panzer im Streifen die
israelische Armee stößt erneut für kurze
Einsätze in den Norden des Gebiets vor
und Tote in Main ein Amokläufer schießt
an mehreren Orten in einer Kleinstadt um
sich und ist immer noch auf der
flussr wieder ein Krisengipfel der EU
neben Ukraine und Migration geht es in
Brüssel vor allem darum wie man dazu
beitragen kann einen Flächenbrand im
Nahen Osten zu verhindern und Zivilisten
zu schützen
um humanitäre Hilfe in den Gazastreifen
zu bekommen soll es einen Aufruf zur
Feuerpausen geben doch schon da
offenbaren sich die Differenzen zwischen
den Staats und Regierungschefs aus
Brüssel Gunnar
Krüger wie hält es die EU mit Hamas und
Israel in Brüssel sagen fast alle das
Gleiche aber jeder betont was
anderes das wird da drin eine tiefe
ernste Diskussion wir sind für Israels
Recht zur Selbstverteidigung
doch die Bevölkerung von Gaza leidet
unter Israels Luftschlägen und der
Blockade braucht es jetzt humanitäre
Fenster oder eine humanitäre Pause wo
und wie lang sollen also Waffen
schweigen in den Worten steckt
gipfelstreit ich bin klar für eine
humanitäre Pause ich denke die ist
dringend nötig denn die Bilder und das
Leid die wir über die Medien vom
Gazastreifen sehen kann man nicht
akeptieren israel hat das Recht auf
Hamas zu zielen aber das kann keine
Entschuldigung sein für willkürliche
Aktionen für die Blockade von
Gaza humanitäre Korridore und Pausen die
Mehrzahl könnte der Kompromiss sein der
Kanzler setzt darauf nimmt Israel nur
sanft in die Pflicht mit einem Lob
Israel ist ein demokratischer Staat mit
sehr humanitären Prinzipien die ihn
leiten und deshalb kann man sicher sein
dass die israelische Armee auch bei dem
was sie macht die Regeln beachten wird
die sich aus dem Völkerrecht ergeben da
habe ich keinen Zweifel andere in der EU
wählen andere Töne nur wenn Sie sich
einig werden hat Europas Wort Gewicht
Ulf röer in Brüssel unabhängig davon wie
dieser Gipfel ausgeht welchen Einfluss
hat die EU überhaupt in der
Region also die entscheidende macht ist
natürlich Amerika sie hat zwei
Flugzeugträger in Stellung gebracht in
der Region das beeindruckt und das
schüchtert auch ein da kann Europa nicht
mithalten aber unterhalb dieser
gigantischen militärischen Schwelle hat
eigentlich Europa Einfluss diplomatisch
und eben auch weil sie viel Geld in
diese Region schicken aber es ist eben
sehr entscheidend dass Europa mit einer
Stimme spricht und das war bisher nicht
der Fall man hat das Gefühl es gibt zwei
Lager und Europa tritt belehrend auf das
will man jetzt eben ändern man will eben
nicht nur ein Formelkompromiss
hinkriegen sondern einen Kompromiss der
wirklich trägt und dass man danach eben
nicht mehr auseinander geht und sich
weiter streitet das tut man im Moment
man sitzt zusammen das wird sehr sehr
schwierig aber das ist das Ziel die
Einschätzung unseres eu-korrespondenten
danke nach Brüssel Ulf
Röller die Terrororganisation Hamas
vernichten das ist erklärtes Ziel
Israels das Militär hat nach eigenen
Angaben innerhalb von 24 Stunden 250
Luftangriffe auf den Gazastreifen
geflogen gleichzeitig feuert die Hamas
von dort weiter Raketen auf Israel in
der Nacht hatte Israel kurzzeitig auch
Panzer in den Gazastreifen geschickt
jetzt Tim
Kröger diese Bilder der israelischen
Streitkräfte sollen zeigen wie Einheiten
in der Nacht zu einer größeren aber
zeitlich begrenzten bodenoperation in
den Gasastreifen einmarschieren dabei
sein kämpferinrichtungen und
Infrastruktur der Hamas angegriffen
worden damit sollte die nächste Stufe
des Krieges vorbereitet
werden der militinsatz wird schon bald
mit mehrkräften in die nächste Phase
gehen auch die israelischen Luftangriffe
auf Gaza gehen weiter
Satellitenaufnahmen sollen die
Zerstörung seit dem Beginn der Attacken
nach dem Hamas Massaker am 7 Oktober
zeigen nach Angaben der Hamas seien auch
50 der Geiseln unter den Opfern eine
Bestätigung dafür gibt es nicht der
katarische Nachrichtensender aljasira
berichtet dass gestern
Familienangehörige seines Gaza
korrespondentenel aldachu verletzt und
getötet
wurden das ist wirklich eine große
Katastrophe vor allem weil eine so große
Zahl an Frauen und Kindern betroffen war
als das Haus getroffen
wurde weiterhin bemühen sich
Hilfsorganisationen dringend benötigte
Lebensmittel Medikamente und andere
Güter in den Gasastreifen zu bringen und
immer wieder schlagen auch Raketen aus
Gaza in Israel ein so wie hier heute in
der Stadt Pet zwei Menschen wden
Dail auch in der Ukraine wird
weiterekämp besonders heftig im Süden
und Osten des Landes seit Monaten dauern
die Gefechte um avdevka in der Region
Donetzk an dort hat die russische Armee
in den vergangenen Wochen ihre Angriffe
verstärkt vor Kriegsbeginn lebten in der
industriestatt mehr als 30 000 Menschen
jetzt sind es nur noch etwa
1000 eine ausführliche Analyse zur
aktuellen Lage in der Ukraine liefern
unsere Kollegen von ZDF heute live um
19:30 Uhr auf auf unseren Social Media
Kanälen und in der ZDF heute App nach
Deutschland da legten die Steuerschätzer
ihre Herbstprognose vor und die ist eher
ernüchternd so gehen die Schätzer bis
2027 zwar von
23,3 Milliarden Euro mehr Einnahmen aus
als noch im Frühjahr fürs kommende Jahr
erwarten Sie für Bund Länder und
Gemeinden aber nur rund 1,9 Milliarden
mehr insgesamt
964,1 Milliarden für dieses Jahr
korrigieren die Schätzer ihre Prognose
für den Bund sogar noch weiter nach
unten Patrizia Wiedemeier berereichtet
er kam mit einer klaren Botschaft es war
gleich der erste Satz des
Finanzministers leicht abgeändert wurde
dieses dann mehrfach wiederholt die
Staatseinnahmen entwickeln sich im
Rahmen der Erwartungen das ist eine gute
Nachricht und es ist zugleich eine
schlechte Nachricht für all diejenigen
die jetzt auf zusätzliche finanzielle
Möglichkeiten gehofft hatten denn neue
Verteilungsspielräume die gibt es nicht
die Schuldenbremse gelte wer mehr Geld
ausgeben wolle müsse sagen wo das auf
der anderen Seite eingespart werden soll
so Lindner eine klare Absage an
Wirtschaftsminister habbeck der am
Dienstag seine industriestrategie
vorstellte und mehr Geld fordert unter
anderem für eine Kompensation der hohen
Energiekosten wir haben Spielraum wir
müssen Prioritäten setzen und wir müssen
gleichzeitig investieren jetzt ist die
Zeit zu investieren in die Zukunft
unserer Wirtschaft in die Infrastruktur
in die Bahn in die Bildung all das was
Deutschland braucht um auch
zukunftsfähig zu sein ob die gesenkte
Umsatzsteuer für die Gastronomie in
coronazeiten eingeführt bleiben kann
muss jetzt der Bundestag entscheiden und
auch Entlastung für die Bürger für
Inflation und hohe Energiepreise
fraglich wir müssen jetzt Richtung
wachstumssteuern und Investitionen ieren
das heißt aber dass die Ampel in ihrem
Haushalt wirklich umbauen müsste weg von
Sozialabgaben hin zu Mitteln mit denen
man Investitionen fördert genau das
findet nicht statt doch auch in den
nächsten Jahren wird das Geld knapp sein
denn langfristig werden die Zahlungen an
die EU wieder höher ausfallen und die
Sondervermögen für Bundeswehr und Klima
müssen im Haushalt verbucht
werden im Kampf gegen die Inflation hat
die Europäische Zentralbank ihren Kurs
geändert nach Zeh Zinserhöhungen
hintereinander ließen die Währungshüter
den Leitzins unverändert bei
4,5% zuletzt hatte sich der Preisanstieg
im Euroraum deutlich abgeschwächt
experten erwarten nun eine Phase
stabiler
Zinsen in Berlin haben die
Tarifverhandlungen für den öffentlichen
Dienst der Länder begonnen sie betreffen
insgesamt rund 3 Millionen Menschen zum
Auftakt verschafften sich die
Beschäftigten mit einer Kundgebung gehö
die Gewerkschaften fordern 10,5% mehr
Gehalt mindestens aber 500 € bei einer
Laufzeit von 12 Monaten zu viel sagen
die Länder man brauche eine
Verständigung die fair und leistbar
sei es war nicht nur die Affäre um ein
antisemitisches Flugblatt im Schulranzen
von Hubert eiwanger in Bayern rumpelte
es in der Koalition zwischen CSU und
Freien Wählern vor allem zwischen den
beiden Chefs trotzdem haben Söder und
und eiwanger jetzt zweieinhalb Wochen
nach der Wahl einen neuen
Koalitionsvertrag besiegelt darin ein
zusätzliches Ministerium für die Freien
Wähler und eine Erklärung gegen
Antisemitismus aus München Simon
Pfanzelt es ist heute viel vom Neuanfang
die Rede nach weniger als zwei Wochen
steht der Koalitionsvertrag zwischen CSU
und Freien Wählern mehr als 70 neue
Projekte verspricht die Staatsregierung
ganz vorn dabei dürfte das Projekt
Versöhnung stehen dass wir nach all den
ja schamützeln auch in den vergangenen
Monaten im Wahlkampf jetzt wirklich
gemeinsam das Ziel ins Auge wieder
fassen Bayern gemeinsam nach vorne zu
bringen lieber Markus Süder vielen Dank
wir haben neues Vertrauen zueinander
gefasst das kann man glaube ich sagen
sodass wir mit gutem Gewissen und volle
Überzeugung die neue Staatsregierung
bilden können Söder und eiwanger das war
nie eine Männerfreundschaft immer wieder
knirscht es zwischen den beiden zuletzt
hat die flugblattaffäre um eiwanger viel
Vertrauen gekostet
jetzt bekommen die Freien Wähler einen
Ministerposten mehr nach einem
Rekordergebnis bei der Landtagswahl
natürlich das ist klar war und ist keine
Liebesheirat oder auch keine
kuschelkoalition aber sie wird
verlässlich arbeiten und sie ist
belastbar auf Seite 1 sagen sie
Antisemitismus und Rassismus jetzt den
Kampf an eine Abgrenzung zur AFD die
aber auch als Versuch gelesen werden
kann eiwanger einzufangen der immer
wieder durch populistische Töne auffällt
außerdem sollen bayerische Schüler sich
künftig eine Viertelstunde pro Woche mit
demokratischen Werten und der Verfassung
beschäftigen ob der Streit mit Söder
jetzt endgültig beigelegt sei wird
eiwanger heute gefragt und weiß nie was
die Zukunft bringt aber wir wir geben
uns beide Mühe und an mir soll es nicht
liegen und dann ihm auch
nicht es war der erste gemeinsame
Auftritt von Söder und eiwanger seit
Wochen beide bemühen sich heute dass ihn
die neugewonnene Harmonie nicht gleich
wieder durch die Finger
leitet das daxunternehmen Siemens Energy
benötigt offenbar staatliche Hilfe der
Münchner Hersteller von
Kraftwerkstechnik und Windturbinen
bestätigte Verhandlungen mit dem Bund es
geht um Kreditbürgschaften bis zu 15
Milliarden Euro Siemens Energy kämpft
seit Jahren mit Qualitätsproblemen und
Milliardenverlusten bei einem spanischen
Tochterunternehmen bundesweit sind
Polizei und Staatsanwaltschaft gegen ein
zwerk der rechtsextremen Musikszene
vorgegangen es gab ratzien in mehreren
Bundesländern und auf der Insel Mallorca
der mutmaßliche Kopf der Gruppe wurde
festgenommen sie soll
menschenverachtende und volksverhetzende
Musik produziert und vertrieben haben in
Deutschland aber auch
international schauen wir in den
Nordosten der USA die Kleinstadt lewison
in Maine beherrscht dort seit der Nacht
die Schlagzeilen ein Amokläufer hat
mindestens 18 Menschen erschossen 13
weitere erlitten Verletzungen der
ehemalige US-Soldat hatte in einer
Bowlingbahn und in einem Grillrestaurant
des Feuer eröffnet und der Albtraum ist
noch nicht zu Ende der Täter ist noch
nicht gefunden Jennifer
Girke nur Weg in Sicherheit eigentlich
wollten sie einen schönen Abend haben
gingen zum Bowen als plötzlich ein Mann
mit einer halbautomatischen Waffe auf
sie
losging aus dem Nichts kam er einfach
rein und gab einen lauten Knall ich bin
einfach auf die Bahn runtergerutscht und
dort wo die Pins sind auf die Maschine
hochgeklettert von der Bowlingbahn zog
der Schütze weiter in eine Bar auch dort
eröffnete er das Feuer anhand von
Aufnahmen einer Überwachungskamera
konnte die Polizei den 40-Jährigen
Robert cart als Verdächtigen
identifizieren ein waffenausbilder mit
rund 20 Jahren Erfahrung diente im
Militär er ist gefährlich bewaffnet und
weiterhin auf der Flucht war womöglich
mit diesem Auto unterwegs doch viel mehr
ist noch nicht bekannt kein Motiv kein
Aufenthaltsort die Ermittler scheinen
ratlos reagieren auf Nachfragen
gereizt wir suchen aktiv nach ihm wenn
ich die Antworten auf diese Fragen
wüsste wäre das ja eine andere
Pressekonferenz wir kennen seinen
Aufenthaltsort nicht dabei werde ich es
belassen die Schulen in der Umgebung
sind geschlossen Anwohner aufgefordert
sich in Innenräumen aufzuhalten während
die Polizei mit einem Großaufgebot im
Einsatz ist um den Flüchtenden zu
fassen ich bitte die Öffentlichkeit auch
weiterhin auf ihre Sicherheit zu achten
und so viel Geduld wie möglich mit dem
Prozess zu
haben Geduld haben das ist viel verlangt
die Bevölkerung hofft dass die Gefahr
bald gebannt ist acht der Todesopfer
sind bereits identifiziert ihre Familien
benachrichtigt in Mexiko sind beim
Durchzug von Hurrican Otis mindestens 27
Menschen ums Leben gek kommen viele
werden noch vermisst besonders schwer
getroffen hat es den Badeort akapulko
Windgeschwindigkeiten von fast 270 km
pro Stunde richteten massive
Verwüstungen an Erdrutsche beschädigten
die Autobahn die die Region mit Mexiko
Stadt verbindet auch die örtliche
Kommunikation ist nach Stromausfällen
eingeschränkt selbst Experten waren
überrascht wie es so schnell an Kraft
gewinnen
konnte und jetzt Fußball Champion li
Norbert da lief es gestern Abend bestens
für die zwei deutschen Clubs ja kann man
wohl sagen zunächst zum BVB starke
Leistung in Newcastle taktisch und
spielerisch zum können kam aber auch
noch Glück dazu zwei Lattentreffer der
Engländer in den Schlussminuten am Ende
ein knapper ein:0
Sieg es ist der erste BVB Jubel in
dieser Champions League Saison in
Newcastle gelingt zum ersten Mal ein Tor
damit der erste Sieg und auch der
Torschütze ist neu in der Königsklasse
Felix matcher vollendet einen perfekten
Angriff kurz vor der Pause zum 10 ein
Treffer der das Spiel entscheidet auch
weil Torwart Gregor Kobel immer wieder
den Weg im richtigen Moment versperrt
und Newcastle in der Schlussphase
zweimal nur die Latte trifft am Ende
haben wir haben wir dann natürlich auch
sehr viel verteidigen müssen sehr viel
Leidenschaft investiert ein bisschen
Glück gehabt heraussagenden tröter
gehabt und am Ende sind wir natürlich
sehr sehr zufrieden mit dem Ergebnis
heute mit vier Punkten ist der BVB jetzt
wieder gut dabei im Champions League
Geschäft zwei Wochen kommt Newcastle
nach
Dortmund ja und auch Leipzig lieferte
gestern Abend und steht schon mit einem
Bein im Achtelfinale das 1:0 durch David
Raum nach 12 Minuten gegen Roter Stern
Belgrad dann chavi Simons in der 59
Minute zum längstfälligen 2:0 nach dem
überraschenden Anschlusstreffer der
Serben traf dann Dani Olmo in der 84
Minute zum 3:1
entstand und zu den DFB Frauen die will
ja der neue Interimstrainer Horst
Rubisch wieder auf Erfolgskurs bringen
morgen Abend in der nations League
geht's gegen Wales allerdings ohne
toptorjägerin Alexandra Popp ein Sieg
gegen Wales eigentlich eine
Pflichtaufgabe bei der Women's nations
League aber der kurzfristige Ausfall von
Alexandra Pop bringt durchaus Unruhe ins
Team und die Frage wer die topstürmerin
ersetzen soll der Marschplan wird ja
gleiche bleiben und wir haben auch
andere Spieler die auch durchschießen
können und die müssen halt mal hier
reinspringen in diese Richtung unter
Host rubesch müssen die
Olympiasiegerinnen von Rio zu
alterstärke zurückfinden ich glaube
einfach an diese Mannschaft ich glaube
an diese Qualität die sie hat und das
hat sie jetzt im Training auch gezeigt
nach der Niederlage gegen Dänemark und
dem 4:0 Sieg gegen Island ist das dritte
Gruppenspiel gegen Wales entscheidend
für das Weiterkommen es geht um die
Olympischen Spiele im nächsten Jahr und
am Dienstag schon das nächste Spiel wier
gegen Island danke gerne zum Schluss
noch ein kurzer Blick in das wohl
berühmteste unbe Dorf der Welt dort
sorgt neuerdings ein achtsamkeitsguru
für Wirbel im heute erscheinenden
asterixband die weiße Iris will der
alles verbieten was Spaß macht
Raufereien mit Römern z.B fettige
Wildschweine sowieso gallische Lebensart
eben aber wer die pfiffigen Dorfbewohner
pardon Dorfbewohner innen kennt weiß am
Ende raucht man sich wieder
zusammen das Wetter bleibt ch trüb und
mild aber zum Wochenende tut sich was
was erzählt gleich Katja horneffer das
heute journal um
mit Anne gellineck wir wünschen Ihnen
alles Gute und einen schönen Abend bis
morgen wenn Sie mögen auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen guten Abend heute zogen
viele Wolken von West nach Ost über uns
hinweg und jetzt formiert sich gerade
über Frankreich ein neues Tief und
dieses neue tief zieht bis morgen Abend
über die Alpen und Süddeutschland weiter
ostwärts über Österreich dann in den
Osten das bringt Regen mit und in den
Alpen das sehen Sie an der rosafarbe
auch etwas Schnee heute Nacht regn es
kräftig in der Südhälfte nordöstlich der
Elbe gibt's einige Regenschauer und die
Temperaturen sinken auf 11° am oberrein
und bis 6° in der ckermark morgen
erwarten uns Höchsttemperaturen zwischen
10° im vogland oder auch an der Ostsee
und bis zu 17° am oberreim Morgen regnet
es erstmal kräftig aber dann zieht der
Regen ja ostwärts ab und dann kann es am
Alpenrand ganz freundlich werden und
hinter dem Regen lockern die Wolken
westlich des Rins und am oberrein auch
mal auf dann entwickeln sich Schauer
vielleicht auch mal kurze Gewitter an
diesem Wetter ändert sich auch am
Samstag wenig am Sonntag wird es dann
hier im Nordwesten richtig stürmisch und
dann kann es mit föhenunterstützung in
Bayern für 20° reichen und ganz ähnlich
startet dann auch die neue Woche ich
wünsche ihn noch einen schönen Abend